for those of you who don't know CPAC is
the Conservative Political Action
Conference and it's where conservatives
meet every year to strategize rally
collaborate and really just get excited
about their favorite politicians see
backs just kind of like the Mac up for
me it's like a super bowl I love it for
many years it didn't seem like many
opinions were changing but something
very important has been emerging at the
conference over the last few years a
generational divide on social issues
that only seems to be growing do you
feel like conservatives need to evolve
on social issues what do you mean by
evolved well legalizing marijuana for
instance so the Republican Party's
doomed if they don't change their
stances on medical marijuana or even
recreational marijuana I was accused of
using them which I come on you'd use
marijuana come on you've used marijuana
you used it I'm one hundred percent for
legalizing everything but that's just me
maybe a little bit during college maybe
after Colin man maybe you explored a
little bit in high school you can go to
college didn't go to college what would
you do with your talks about marijuana
it's a product like any other and it
doesn't hurt anybody and it's safer than
alcohol pot smokers love America they
love anything as long as they can smoke
pot and all high and mighty and I'm
sorry can do that again oh that's what
we are what about with gay marriage is
it something that's like not a big deal
to you anymore for me it never was a big
deal I believe in marriage being an
institution that is between a man and a
woman if they want to find but don't
shove it down my throat in no way shape
or form is that going to like hurt the
country if we if we like in that battle
they want equal rights for everything
and yeah they do want to go right
through everything we've all grown up
and we have like gay friends so like
same-sex marriage isn't really something
that at least most of the one most of
the people I've talked to we're like
focusing on as far as like trying to ban
it I think it's really unfair
reach a free market and to preach
liberty and freedom yet at the same time
the advocating for laws that you know
tell you who who you can and can't be
within your own bedroom of course it's
not all young conservatives me I
personally believe that there is right
there is wrong that marriage is between
one man and one woman hi and of course
it's not all older conservatives to do
you think they being against gay
marriage is holding conservatives back
not even for marriage I'm for that the
government being in it I'm poor if you
want to get married they'll get it
faster although some conservatives
refuse to accept the changing world
around them okay what about a keep my
blinders on can you talk about that you
keep your blinders on no I just look
forward young people are growing up with
more choices and more options in their
lives do you smoke weed come on no
comment